now we begin this Monday night with a
Fox News Alert the department of energy
they are now finally admitting the
obvious truth covid-19 was apparently
developed in that by Chinese scientists
at the Wuhan Institute of virology
likely through gain of function research
now the deadly disease somehow leaked
out of the lab and it infected the
entire world and by the way China knew
it the entire time side note a sloppy
attempt to cover up and then that all
ensued from the Communist Chinese and of
course their corrupt propagandists in
part that we fund for China and that
would be The Who and maybe even Dr fauci
himself and yet no one has been held
accountable they have yet to this point
even wanted to admit the truth which was
obvious now a message from President
Reagan is more relevant than ever quote
the nine most terrifying words in the
English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to help in other
words do not put your trust in the
federal government and the officials
that work in government because sadly
over and over again they are constantly
lying to you the American people or
making it all up as they go along
especially during life and death
scenarios for example if you go back two
days after the terror attack on 9 11
well the head of the APA at the time
told New Yorkers that the error Ground
Zero is safe to breathe the EPA was
wrong and now many are dead others
seriously ill even today from believing
that lie and breathing that air here's
another glaring example remember the
Affordable Care Act Barack Obama
repeatedly promising all Americans can
keep their doctor keep their plans the
average American family would save
around twenty five hundred dollars a
year well after the bill passed millions
of Americans lost their doctors Millions
lost their plans prices skyrocketed out
of sight and almost half the country has
only one Obamacare exchange option
that's it they lie to you over and over
again even far left political political
fact called this the LIE of the year and
get this just last week pothole Pete
blaming Donald Trump's deregulation for
the disaster in East Palestine well even
the radical left-wing Washington Post
they just reviewed every single possible
regulatory change under Donald Trump and
they found that none of them contributed
to the Ohio train derailment and then
you got pothole Pete the Biden
Administration the media mob flat out
lying to you the American people again
and again now of course the lies
surrounding covid-19 were on a whole
other level they demanded that we wear
masks now top scientists are saying uh
Mass did not stop they did not slow the
spread of covid-19 at all pretty much
saying that they were useless they
mandated those vaccines remember even
for for those with natural immunity
prior from a prior infection well as it
turns out natural immunity is a stronger
protection against the virus remember
they told you that if you got the
vaccine that would stop the spread of
covid-19 they were wrong again remember
they told you if you got vaccinated you
would never get covered you would never
spread covid wrong again how many
Americans believe these lies and then
there was the chorus of misinformation
surrounding the origins of covet 19. now
despite the fact that the covet outbreak
clearly started in Wuhan in China the
site of the Wuhan Institute for virology
a lab that was well known for gain of
function research and research on
coronaviruses many on the left just
could not fathom the possibility that
covet originated in that lab the World
Health Organization they immediately
ruled out the possibility of a lab leak
Dr fauci claimed that there was no
evidence that Covenant was made in a
Chinese lab he had been told otherwise
by a scientist in an email very early on
the Washington Post called the lab leak
hypothesis a quote debunked conspiracy
theory Facebook they censored posts that
referred to the virus as man-made even
Forbes called it a conspiracy theory and
the echo chamber was in full gear take a
look
Tom Cotton a couple of days ago uh
spouting and conspiracy theory to the
Chinese made this virus up in a lab
conservative talk show host Rush
Limbaugh with zero proof suggesting a
Chinese bio weapon lab is to blame we
know that it's been debunked that this
virus was man-made or modified or
anything like that Dr Anthony fauci
rejected the conspiracy that coronavirus
was man-made in a lab in Wuhan China and
yet this week Donald Trump is still
pushing the debunked Buncombe despite
his own intelligence community's
findings that that is simply not true if
you look at the evolution of the virus
in bats and what's out there now
is very very strongly leaning towards
this could not have been artificially or
deliberately manipulated well Brett I'm
really sorry that the lab leak has
become such a distraction for so many
people because frankly we still don't
know there is no evidence really to say
most of the scientific Community myself
included think that is a possibility but
far more likely this was a natural way
in which a virus left a bat
oh totally completely debunked a
conspiracy theory just like uh
trump-russia collusion really happened
no they were wrong on that too uh they
were wrong on Hunter Biden's laptop how
many Americans believe their lies how
many would directly hurt or worse as a
result of these lies now of course they
weren't even looking for the truth and
time and time again all in an effort to
get Donald Trump the mob and the media
they denied reality they denied the
truth in this case they echoed nothing
but Chinese propaganda all while then
president Trump was telling the truth
take a look
calling this the Chinese virus there are
reports of dozens of incidents of bias
against Chinese Americans in this
country your own Aid secretary Azar says
he does not use this term he says
ethnicity does not cause the virus why
do you keep using this
it's not racist at all no not at all it
comes from China
that's why it comes from China as you
know China tried to say at one point
maybe this stuff now that it was caused
by American soldiers that can't happen
it's not going to happen not as long as
I'm president
now Trump was right the virus did come
from China in fact it was apparently
developed by by China at a lab partially
funded by you the American people under
Anthony fauci's leadership at the NIH
millions of U.S tax dollars were
funneled via a third party the Eco
Health Alliance to the Wuhan Institute
of virology that was a lab well known
for a couple of things I just stated for
example one that their controversial
gain of function research too they're
sloppy safety protocols if you even want
to call them that uh and you know they
were known for uh also studying
coronaviruses so mark my words there's
got to be accountability or this will
happen again do you really ever going to
trust your government on any issue
involving your health or your family's
health hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get anywhere else